conservative radio personality rush
limbaugh died wednesday morning at the
age of 70.
limbaugh's wife catherine announced on
his radio show that he died of lung
cancer
limbaugh was one of the most popular
talk radio personalities in the country
he launched his nationally syndicated
radio show in 1988
which boasted an audience of 15 million
a week at the show's peak
his popularity helped him land the 11th
spot on the forbes 2020 celebrity 100
list
his crude and provocative style earned
him a large and loyal following
but also left many offended with his
commentary on race and gender
limbaugh was one of the leading voices
of the conservative movement and is
considered to be monumental in shaping
the modern republican party
in 2020 after being diagnosed with lung
cancer
then president donald trump awarded
limbaugh the presidential medal of
freedom